you know contrary to what some people
think the earth isn't the center of the
universe but
what if it was
what if those medieval astronomers were
right and everything does revolve around
you
how would this change what we know about
the sun
in what ways would the other planets
move around us
and
how would this affect your everyday life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the earth was the center of
the solar system
about one millennium ago it was widely
accepted that the earth was the center
of the universe
if you were an ancient human looking at
the night sky
you'd see the sun the moon and the stars
seeming to rotate around you
this was the geocentric model of the
solar system
it put the earth right at the center of
it all and this model was used for a
long time
from about 550 bce
until the 17th century
eventually more advanced scientific
observations and knowledge meant that
this idea could no longer be supported
it was replaced by the heliocentric
model
which places the sun at the center of
our solar system
but
just because
it's simpler
doesn't mean it's true what are you
talking about man what if all the crazy
complications of a geocentric universe
were actually correct
if the earth was the center of the solar
system you'd have to unlearn a lot of
what you know about the universe
the earth would now be in the middle of
everything
surrounding us would be several layers
of other celestial orbits
right next to us would be the moon
then the sun then venus mercury mars and
the rest of the planets of the solar
system
beyond that a sphere containing all the
stars and beyond that
the end of the universe as we know it
if this reordering meant the laws of
gravity stayed the same
then the sizes of the earth and the sun
would have to change dramatically
our planet would need to be
bigger and the sun
would have to be smaller
and not just by a little
the largest planet in the solar system
now is jupiter and its mass is only 0.1
of the sun's
and jupiter is over 300 times more
massive than the earth so
this would require some significant
changes in our planetary neighborhood
of course some significant changes might
improve your life and with grammarly
premium every suggestion can take your
writing to the next level grammarly's
vocabulary choices make every word count
whether i'm pounding out a script or
replying to an email and it works on all
my devices
even in my browser so if i'm at the
office or on the train or even floating
through space i can write with
confidence and clarity so cut down on
your editing time and sign up now to get
twenty percent off grammarly premium at
grammarly.com slash what if that's a
whole twenty percent off at g r a m a r
l y dot com slash what if you know
considering the sun is fading from sight
grammarly premium might be your last ray
of light
a smaller sun would no longer be capable
of powering itself with fusion so you'd
be getting a lot less sunlight
this would have enormous effects on the
climate and the habitability of earth
temperatures would plummet and they
would keep dropping until the earth
turned into a giant snowball
as for the other planets they would no
longer orbit in their elliptical
patterns
instead the planets would all revolve
around us at different speeds but the
moon's orbit wouldn't be uniform
its orbit would change every month
okay that's a bit chaotic
and here's a strange part for all the
stargazing earthlings
sometimes the planets would look like
they were moving backward
that's because the planets wouldn't
simply revolve around the earth
they would also follow their own mini
orbit called the epicycle
and that would result in
this funky path around the earth
at least the earth would still have its
seasons
but not because of the earth's axis
instead it would be because the sun
would move up and down the celestial
equator as it was orbiting us
it would heat the northern hemisphere at
one point and the southern hemisphere at
another
is this geocentric model giving you a
headache
well maybe it's time you listen to the
overwhelming evidence that you
are not at the center of the universe
after all
but
maybe not all of the old theories are
wrong
maybe there is an alien civilization
hiding within our planet and you need to
look deeper under the surface of your
world to find it
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]